[Musique]
Michel David Chantal Hébert bonsoir
bonsoir
David johnstun je on va écouter pierre
Poirier aujourd'hui mais d'abord il y a
un sondage il y aura pas de tableau mais
je vous donne les les chiffres il y a 27
% des Canadiens qui disent le croire
croire en sa crédibilité bon ben on les
a que dit j'en ai pas de tableau 27% oui
non et 40 je ne sais pas donc c'est
intéressant parce que c'est comme alors
voici ce que ça donnait à la Chambre des
communes monsieur Poirier en question
en répondant monsieur Johnson a dit mais
il travaille pas pour le Parlement il
travaille pour le gouvernement et le
Premier ministre c'est ça le problème
monsieur le Président que 27% des
Canadiens ont confiance en lui pour
faire ce travail petite finalement quand
je dis débutant et non mais un juge
indépendant pour un enquête je ne crois
pas que Monsieur dans un peu continuer
de faire ce travail à cause de cet
espérance et je ne suis pas d'accord
avec sa décision de rester dans la poste
le fait que on a cette approche de notre
rapport spécial c'était le mauvais chose
à faire au début j'ai dit au
gouvernement libéral Premier ministre on
aurait dû on aurait dû déclencher une
enquête publique
bon alors évidemment c'est au lendemain
de cette motion qui a été votée à la
Chambre des communes les députés non
plus confiance dans David Johnson une
majorité Chantal est-ce que d'abord
est-ce que les chiffres vous étonnent ou
pas 27 qui le croit 33 non 43 ils savent
pas du tout de quoi il retourne bon le
chiffre qui m'intéresse le plus très
franchement c'est le calanque et
quelques
parce que 43% ça fait deux mois et demi
qu'on parle de ça à la Chambre des
communes et à la Une les journaux en
particulier en anglais et d'arriver à un
taux de pénétration qui exclut
43% presque la moitié des électeurs
c'est pas des gens qui s'informent pas
ça c'est des gens qui ont décidé qu'ils
allaient passer leur tour sur cette
question là et c'est le chiffre qui va
le plus conforter le gouvernement cela
dit et en marge du sondage la décision
de David Johnson rester en poste
refaire ou bien une certaine surdité à
la réalité politique ou bien une
certaine nonchalance parce qu'à la fin
sans égard à ce sondage quand la moitié
des gens s'en foutent ou sont pas
intéressés et qu'il y en a à peine 27 %
qui croit que vous faites un bon travail
et vous êtes vraiment rendu sur la base
puis réduire je suis parti libérale qui
serait probablement d'accord avec à peu
près n'importe quel déclaration du Parti
libéral fédéral donc
pour quelqu'un qui est normalement en
poste pour restaurer la confiance en la
démocratie électorale et parlementaire
c'est particulier de s'accrocher quand
une majorité d'élus de 4 parties vous
demandent de vous effacer Michel
là-dessus Chantal parle de surdité ou de
ou en fait il s'abreuve de cette
controverse puis dit ben justement plus
vous voulez me chasser plus je vais
rester droit dans son esprit puis plus
je vais rester et puis il peut lui et
Monsieur Trudeau peuvent à partir du
chiffre que vous évoquiez le 40% se dire
bon d'une part les Canadiens sont pas
accrochés à cette affaire-là et plus le
temps va passer plus il risque de
décrocher bon là la période difficile
c'est celle qui nous sépare de la
journéement des travaux aux chambres des
communes le 23 juin après ça l'été va
arriver tout le monde va partir en
vacances à la fin de l'été les audiences
de Monsieur Johnson vont commencer
jusqu'à la fin octobre c'est maman est
bonne pendant ce temps là j'ai
l'impression que il va falloir d'une
certaine façon donner la chance au
coureur à dire bon mais là on va écouter
ce qui va se dire dans les audiences
publiques puis à la fin d'octobre
j'ai l'impression que les gens vont dire
bonbons assez et on pense à autre chose
alors on fait le dos rond on a tendance
ce qui ne veut pas dire que la
crédibilité de Monsieur Johnson va
augmenter mais c'est simplement que on
va se détacher de cette question là dans
le sondage de léger il y a une autre
question le sol on a vraiment pas le
tableau c'est là mais je vous le donne
parce que c'est intéressant on pose la
question est-ce que le gouvernement
Trudeau gère bien et il y a seulement 28
%
corrigez moi en régie là c'est j'ai pris
28% des Canadiens qui disent que Trudeau
a bien géré la crise
et 47% qui qui disent qui le mal géré
mon corps là c'est pas 65 c'est comme si
Chantal que comme disait les gens
écoutent mais il y en a qui il faut dire
que c'est une histoire complexe
c'est pas juste une histoire complexe
les gens ça doit être aussi ce qui
arrive à Michel les gens me parlent de
plein de sujets et je suis combien de
gens m'ont parlé du dossier de
l'ingénieur chinoise des gens dans le
quotidien dans l'autobus au marché
ailleurs déjà qui m'ont parlé de
politique c'est quand même pas mal de
monde 0
m'ont parlé bon peut-être que au Québec
on en parle moins qu'ailleurs c'est
totalement possible je pense que les
sondages le montrent mais moi je vais
vous parler d'un autre sondage Léger qui
est sorti aujourd'hui et que les
conservateurs vont devoir regarder
attentivement parce que c'est un sondage
qui porte sur les intentions de vote au
Canada la vraie affaire pour la plupart
des parties est-ce que ça donne c'est
33% libéraux 31% conservateur
19% pour le NPD 34% pour le bloc au
Québec en clair c'est presque un
copier-coller du résultat de la dernière
élection moi je serai l'opposition
officielle avec un nouveau chef qui
pense qu'il tape à bras raccourci sur le
gouvernement et je me poserai de
sérieuses questions devant ce genre de
chiffre là Michel David il faut pas
parfois sous-estimer le fait que un
sujet peut être très très actif dans une
certaine bulle et que dans la population
générale avant que ça percole puis ça
produit des changements de vote c'est
pas demain la veille non plus tout à
fait il y a beaucoup de sujets comme
ceux-là monsieur Trudeau et monsieur
Legault disait la même chose à propos de
la réforme du mode de scrutin les
spécialistes les commentateurs étaient
bien intéressés à ça et finalement les
deux ont laissé tomber ça et ça a pas
paru le moindrement dans les intentions
de vote que ça soit celle de Monsieur
Trudeau ou celle de monsieur Legault bon
les gérances chinoises on le dit c'est
compliqué et
tous les gens ne voient vraiment pas en
quoi ça les touche dans la vie
quotidienne à côté de l'inflation du
coup des aliments de tout ce que vous
voudrez les chinois ils sont loin alors
il y a je pense pas que Monsieur poignet
peut espérer faire une campagne
électorale en disant qui va régler le
problème de l'ingérence chinoise le
mieux
clairement c'est il va falloir trouver
autre chose très bien
oui
c'est pire que ce que Michel vient de
dire dans le sens où Pierre poillière
sert de distraction en pilotant ce
dossier là presque exclusivement à des
sujets avec lesquels il pourrait faire
mal le gouvernement c'est quand même
particulier c'est qu'il a choisi un
cheval qui veut peut-être qu'il va
peut-être pas galoper tant que ça
puisque vous dites
et pendant ce temps-là pas le cheval
mais les souris dansent sur l'inflation
sur fait la liste pendant ce temps-là on
parle pas de sujets une hausse possible
des taux d'intérêt de la Banque du
Canada
comme l'impression que ça touche pas mal
plus de gens que les questions de
Monsieur pollière dans le moment la
Chambre des communes on change de
capital on savait à Québec réforme
Drainville je vous fais entendre un
certain nombre d'extraits aujourd'hui
deux députés d'élus et aussi de
syndicats et on revient
en ce moment c'est pas vraiment d'une
deuxième réforme en éducation qu'on a
besoin faut arrêter de l'hémorragie on
perd des enseignants légalement
qualifiés à chaque année le rapport de
la vérification générale l'indique
pourquoi faut centraliser pourquoi faut
se réformes là puis pour qu'on s'occupe
pas
de des enseignants puis de leur rôle on
apprend simultanément ce matin que les
plusieurs enseignants n'ont pas les
qualifications pour enseigner à nos
jeunes moi je pense que Bernard
drinville va passer une mauvaise journée
aujourd'hui parce qu'on l'a vu les profs
les parents
même les directions personne n'a demandé
une réforme de structure mais la carte
est obsédée par la réforme de structure
centraliser le pouvoir
est-ce que je me sens vraiment utile
comme parrain impliqué dans les dans les
instances si il y a quelqu'un d'autre
qui peut venir défaire des faire la
décision que je viens de prendre en
consensus sur un consensus avec les
autres partenaires autour de la table on
vient vraiment centraliser auprès du
ministre de l'Éducation beaucoup de
décisions puis on pense que
honnêtement c'est pas de ça dans le
système d'éducation a besoin en ce
moment
le réseau de l'éducation plus efficace
donc on veut le décentraliser mais quand
les résultats sont pas là faut avoir le
poids de changer les personnes qui
prennent les décisions locales donc ça
vient complètement ce que Jean-François
avait fait en abolition comme si on
scolaire et il faut penser aux élèves et
puis c'est sûr qu'on a négocié avec les
syndicats d'enseignants
nous allons résister à la résistance au
changement c'est pas compliqué il y a
beaucoup de résistances au changement à
toutes les fois que tu veux toucher à
quelque chose tu as toujours des lobés
qui se lèvent et qui disent pas moins
pour moi faut surtout pas changer il
faut surtout pas toucher à rien ou
encore faut toucher à quelque chose en
notant que ça me touche pas moi-même
mais il faut pas se laisser arrêter par
ça il faut absolument aller de l'avant
avec ces changements là
Michel David est-ce que Bernard
drinville est armé pour résister
justement à ce à cette opposition au
changement dit-il
il peut faire adopter éventuellement son
projet de loi ça avec la majorité dans
l'acaque dispose c'est pas vraiment ça
le problème ça va être faire en sorte
que ça a un effet concret dans le
système d'éducation dans le réseau et là
le problème de Monsieur Drainville je
pense auprès de la population parce
qu'encore là il y a un débat qui se fait
à deux niveaux un peu comme dans la
gérance chinoise les gens ne voient pas
comment ce qu'il propose quel rapport ce
qu'il propose a avec ce que il semble
dans les écoles ça amènera pas
d'enseignants dans les écoles ça
réparera pas les toits qui coulent et ça
les gens ont effectivement l'impression
que Monsieur
Drainville est encore dans une affaire
de structure dont il voit pas le but et
l'autre histoire c'est que bon le
changement la résistance au changement
vous savez au cours des dernières années
il y a eu beaucoup de changements dont
on peut pas dire nécessairement que ça a
été pour le mieux alors c'est pas parce
que on s'oppose nécessairement parce
qu'on veut s'asseoir sur nos propres
intérêts il peut arriver que des
réformes soient mauvaises
et Monsieur Drainville va avoir affaire
la preuve que lui donner tous les
pouvoirs pour aller se mettre le nez
dans la gestion du système au niveau
local ça va améliorer les choses vous
savez le ministère l'éducation c'est pas
une réputation d'efficacité colossale
mais justement il dit Chantal il dit
pour que ça soit plus efficace je dois
connaître les statistiques les
informations des différents sens
scolaires du Québec et donc je dois me
doter de plus de pouvoir est-ce que ça
ça il arrive à pleines et ça est-ce
qu'il va arriver à plaider ça bon
premier problème c'est que le et donc je
dois avoir plus de pouvoir il y en a pas
fait la preuve c'est pas vrai qu'il faut
avoir plus de pouvoir pour avoir plus de
données parce que c'était vrai
Statistique Canada se présenterait aux
élections fédérales
ça me prend des données donc j'ai besoin
de pouvoir
sur le fond Michel touche au bobo c'est
pas juste des lobés c'est très maladroit
d'ailleurs de balayer sous l'horaire de
la main toutes sortes de groupes qui
sont beaucoup plus en contact avec les
parents qui sont des électeurs en disant
ce sont tous des lobbies peut-être
prendre exemple sur son collègue du B à
la santé qui se rappelle que le syndicat
des infirmières c'est aussi les
infirmières et pas juste un lobby mais
le problème de fond c'est effectivement
que c'est très difficile pour Bernard
brinville de se constituer des appuis
sur son projet de loi alors qui est pas
capable ou qu'il y a pas réussi jusqu'à
présent de démontrer quelle différence
ça va faire dans la salle de classe et
pour de vrai et l'argument ça me prend
des données donc des pouvoirs si moi qui
ai pas une spécialiste en éducation je
vois pas le lien j'imagine que la
plupart des gens vont dire ben ouais il
y en a
comment l'homme pourrait être essentiel
pour arriver à l'autre parce que encore
ce matin il répétait Michel et Chantal
et répétait pour assez le Premier
ministre en fait dans la défense de son
ministre disait si on veut changer des
gens qui sont en poste qui ne font pas
ce qu'on leur demande de faire parce
qu'on veut faire les bonnes choses mais
il faut avoir quand même le pouvoir ça
dites-vous Michel ça aurait pu attendre
ou ça aurait dû être mieux expliqué
quand on lui pose la question bon ok
donnez-nous des exemples de gens qui
veulent pas faire ce que vous voulez
qu'il fasse à part l'épisode de
au Saguenay au pays des bleuets pour la
maternelle 4 ans pour laquelle il y a du
s'excuser il y a pas été capable de nous
donner d'exemple alors je veux bien que
ces gens-là soient de mauvaise foi tout
le temps mais il faudrait en faire la
preuve et ça monsieur Drainville a pas
été capable de le faire Chantal
et entre temps ce qu'on voit sur le
terrain c'est des enseignants des
éducateurs qui portent un système à bout
de bras et qui dans le moment sont en
train de s'installer dans la Résistance
dont il parle alors
essayez de deviner pour avoir vécu ce
genre de dynamique là sous le
gouvernement Couillard de quel côté les
parents vont aller ben c'est ça on se
rappelle des chaînes entre autres mais
ça il y avait des coupures qui faisaient
mal autrement dit même avec la même si
on suppose que c'est la chose qu'il doit
faire il faut être capable de rassembler
Michel Chantal Michel faut être capable
de faut avoir un leadership pour que les
gens nous suivent et puis ce monsieur
monsieur drinville part mal disons avec
disons sa comparaison maladroite entre
les fonctions des députés fonctions des
enseignants il y a une ou peut-être même
deux prises contre lui maintenant il va
falloir voir comment il va se comporter
en commission parlementaire est-ce que
son projet de loi est vraiment
négociable on a vu monsieur Dubé qui est
arrivé au moment de l'étude arctique par
article de son projet de loi sur la
santé avec une cinquantaine
d'amendements qui répondent à toutes
mais certains nombre d'objections qui
ont été émises pendant les audiences
publiques à ce que monsieur drinville va
avoir la souplesse nécessaire
on verra mais disons que quand on l'a vu
fonctionner dans le question de la
Charte de la laïcité il y avait pas mis
beaucoup d'eau dans son vin afin de
l'exercice Chantal conclusion et là on
est dans une dynamique beaucoup plus
style santé et Christian Dubé que style
charte des valeurs ou ils pouvaient
rassembler des gens qui étaient de son
école derrière lui en disant tous ceux
qui résistent ont pas le pas Michel
Chantal bonne soirée merci beaucoup à
très bientôt au revoir au revoir